servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neu
ein video heute probieren wir mal was
besonderes aus aber zuallererst mal
ankündigung einer hand bietet sich das
ja hand kaputt zuallererst die
ausbildungszeit für das gewinnspiel ist
vorbei für das nervt gewinnspiel die
infos zu den gewinnern also die infos
wer gewonnen hat diese nochmal unten
verlinkt das video
es haben sich glaube ich von acht
gewinnern bisher fünf gemeldet vier oder
fünf heißt es fehlen noch einige der
unter dem video kommentiert hat und
diesen coup ihr schneemann video und das
teil gewinnen wollt dann checkt
unbedingt noch mal das video in der
beschreibung der wurden die gewinner
bekannt gegeben
sonst kann es sein dass ihr als gewinner
ausgewählt wurde da aber nichts bekommen
weil ich nicht gemeldet habt das
natürlich doof okay dann schauen wir uns
mal an was wir da im hintergrund sehen
ich frage euch jetzt bestimmt so was ist
das das macht er heute
ich persönlich bin schon länger entfernt
von youtube kacke videos ja das sind
solche videos bei dem leute
irgendwelches bildmaterial nehmen von
irgendwelchen fernsehsendungen oder so
aber dass dann so witzig
zusammenschneiden das komplett neue
sätze entstehen und ich versuche jedes
mal so weg und dachte mir wenn ich mir
eine ablage ist bestimmt für euch auch
witzig deswegen schauen wir uns heute
einfach mal ein youtube video an
das hier ist von soßenbinder dass ein
größerer kanal in der youtube kaka szene
des unten verlinkt check unbedingt man
den kanal ab und seine anderen videos
und auch das hier in der originalfassung
ohne mein gesicht weiß im gesicht ich
möchte findet ihr dass der link dazu ist
in der beschreibung also wie gesagt es
lohnt sich wirklich das abzudecken sind
verdammt witzige videos und jetzt ist
einfach experiment leute ich hab es
sinnvoll nicht ausprobiert mich einfach
gucken was wird sich für euch ist nicht
mehr diese videos anschaut dazu reagiere
ok schauen uns an
hallo mein name ist detlef dee soost und
ich freue mich sehr dass du heute grasen
gegangen ist
ich möchte heute okay leute dieses so so
ein ding was die youtube kacke menschen
immer machen eine ganz persönliche ganz
mit ihr teilen das geheimnis mit dem ich
es geschafft hat innerhalb von zwanzig
wochen sage und schreibe zehn kilo und
aufzubauen muskeln zu verlieren und ein
rundum positives schafft geführt zu
entwickeln was er gesagt ganz ganz
willst du das auch dann bist du hier
genau richtig
jawohl die leute die diese videos
emittieren in dieser suchen werden so
gestört so gestellt wie kann man wie wie
egal was ich getan habe tanzen [ __ ]
oder auch scheiße oder alles in
kombination
nichts hat mich langfristig lust
verlieren lassen das hat mich dass ich
sagen soll das ist ja nicht ganz
jugendfrei ist tanzen [ __ ] und chancen
oder einfach ein mensch etwas alles
gleichzeitig machen zwickt und scheißt
aber das alles hat ihm nicht geholfen
man also mal gucken allein dieses
gesicht wieder was was hat er gemacht
wenn diese drei dinge zusammen nicht
geholfen haben wie hat das hinbekommen
wird das geschafft zu bewogen ein neues
programm zu entwickeln dass es hinten
comics programm
ich freue mich auf dich in diesem sinne
vereinfacht die bombe blockt aber so ich
fange gerne mal an zu heulen wenn ich
lache also holen vor lachen
okay leute das video gerade eben hieß
der fig gürtel falls ihr das besucht ich
hab's euch in der beschreibung auch noch
mal verlinkt und jetzt haben wir noch
ein wunderschönes exemplar das heißt
youtube kacke die geschichte dass sie
das kind nicht ganz einfach aber ich
will noch mal kurz reinschauen leute
liebe diese videos waren
ich werde jetzt mal ausprobieren ob das
lust hier ist für euch das cooles
anzuschauen falls ja schreibt kommentare
falls nicht schreibt auch in die
kommentare
ist einfach ein experiment ich finde man
muss man neue dinge ausprobieren auf
youtube und wird so langweilig mit
diesem bild habe ich ein besonderes
video versprochen habe ich endlich und
ich möchten durch dieses video einfach
jedem einzelnen danken von ganzen ganzen
eine scheiße der unseren alltag würzen
hier leben obwohl er uns die augen
tränen treibt augen schärfen
eine spurensuche zwischen bratwurst und
breit
wenn der bürgermeister höchstpersönlich
der bürgermeister ist dann muss das der
nähe von dijon roche sein
das dorf der bürgermeister
es wurde hier im burgund schon vor
jahrhunderten angebaut
das beste es einfach so wenn der
bürgermeister
der bürgermeister ist ein bus ist dieses
dorf seien die giorgio di soll die
chance sein
die sind die chance eröffnen da hab ich
seit 60 mal durch das dorf heißt der
letzte unabhängige familienbetrieb der
selber im burgund noch nach alten regeln
der städte
aus fünf kölnern wird später ein kilo
hessen am grundrezept hat sich
vielleicht 0 5 0 5 gramm mache mir
später ein ganzes kilo so könnt ihr euch
das vorstellen
es ist unfassbar wie ergiebig diese
produktion ist
leute ich hab wirklich keine ahnung wie
das jetzt auf euch gewirkt hat war es
total random konnte damit was anfangen
ich habe mir den arsch ab gelacht
schreibt unbedingt meine kommentare was
davon halten würde mich interessieren
und alle gewinnspiel teilnehmer
unbedingt das video checken wir haben
vier oder fünf leute ihre gewinne nicht
angenommen haben sagt okay gut das war
es dann so weit von mir
bis zum nächsten mal feedback in die
kommentare macht's gut und ciao